and now for your evening news with Mary
Kish good evening it's Wednesday July
27th and I'm married in this is GameSpot
news so uh what's up with that Amazon
listing you know the one for Metal Gear
Solid five definitive x if you're off to
go look for it it's already gone most of
the listing which was discovered by
reddit it's full of placeholder
information including a release date of
December 31st 2016 pretty much the only
bit of worthwhile info is the name and
even that Metal Gear Solid 5 definitive
X is very vague so what can we gather
from these scraps of info perhaps it's
the definitive edition of the phantom
pain game that includes ground zeroes or
perhaps it's TPP's cosmetic multiplayer
DLC but that name definitive X as
opposed to anything calls into question
what it is we don't even know for sure
if it is a game and it's already been
pulled so stay tuned for more
information on whatever that is back to
you Mary thanks for that story Mary and
now Mike my hearty with the weather 6585
Sonny thanks Mike and now the developer
behind prey explains what the hell prey
is among Bethesda's III reveals this
year was prey a brand new game from
Dishonored developer Arkane studios
there was some confusion what it is
exactly given that it uses the same name
as an existing Bethesda series but
director raphaël colantonio has now
tried to better explain what to expect
echoing what he said at e3 : Tonio said
in a newly released video pray is not a
sequel it's not a remake it has no tie
with the original you have to look at it
like a reimagining of the idea also
despite what you might have thought from
the trailer shown at e3 : Tonio said
it's not horror the psychological
thriller dimension is more around the
theme of identity well that cleared some
of that up back to you Mary thanks for
that Mary and now for sports with Alex
News house
my name is Newhouse and I think the
Giants won for our final story all the
free games you get with PlayStation Plus
in August it's a pretty good chunk of
games this month although one of Zeena's
two games ultra Tron is a cross by title
so it's also available on ps4 and ps3 it
gives both of those platforms three
freebies this month ps4 players get the
upcoming puzzle game tricky towers which
kind of looks like a competitive version
of Tetris where you try and stack
tetrominoes or tetriminos if you're one
of those jerks as high as you can the
other title is rebel galaxy the action
game where you explore the galaxy and a
ship while transporting cargo and
fighting off pirates fans of Firefly in
particular will be pleased on ps3 you're
getting Yakuza 5 v Yakuza game moving on
retro grade a side-scrolling
shoot-'em-up where you're travelling
backward through time it's also gonna be
free also joining ultra Tron on Vita is
pata pon-3 the 2011 PSP sequel to the
rhythm action series you can check out
the full lineup on GameSpot calm these
will all be available starting Tuesday
August 2nd you have until then to claim
to Weis games which includes saints row
get outta hell and fury back to you Mary
so that's all the news I have for you
today
but you're gonna want to check back oh
my god there's a dragon knight in the
GameSpot office do we have a game smoked
ham can we cut